hey Henry can you can you bite my finger
please bite my finger Henry we're never
gonna go viral unless you bite my finger
Henry says good morning uncle Hank it's
Monday Henry you know how I can tell
you're an astronaut like all astronauts
you're wearing space pajamas Henry like
his father wears pajamas until well into
the afternoon we both work from home
Henry why are you so much better lip
than I am you're stealing my light you
seem to have forgotten that this YouTube
channel is called vlogbrothers not vlog
adorable baby having now spent seven
weeks with a newborn I feel like I'm
something of an expert in the field
and while babies could hardly be more
adorable I can't help but come to the
conclusion that babies can be a tiny bit
self-centered did you just punch me in
the face on purpose it's always changed
my diaper feed me offer me comfort give
me a pacifier what about my pacifier
Hank when will Henry give me a pacifier
in fact Hank sometimes it doesn't even
seem like Henry thinks I'm a person it
seems like he thinks I'm some kind of
robot need filler
I am your robot need filler what are
your needs do you need to be nom de but
anyway ain't the weirdest part of the
complete inability of infants to
apprehend that other people also have
needs is that I don't care something
weird and base and nurturing happened to
me when he was born that caused me to
want to like change poopie diapers by
the way Hank no matter how efficient a
diaper changer you are there will always
be one nanosecond between the old diaper
and the new diaper where the bottom is
diaperless and to Henry that moment is
known as poopie time there's something
about being a parent that turns you
weirdly insular so you find yourself
really only caring about the needs of
your kid which is why for instance I
forgot to tell you guys that I had a
book coming out in like 25 days Henry
says Will Grayson Will Grayson available
for pre-order now link in the doobly-doo
thanks but I appreciate the marketing
Hank there's this phrase in the study of
religion ultimate concern your ultimate
concern is the thing or value that you
prize above all others the one you would
die for the one you would kill for now
of course it's pretty easy to go through
life without an ultimate concern for
instance I don't think Henry has one yet
you know cuz he's still in the business
of self-preservation but Hank
nerdfighters that's what I want this
week's theme to be
an ultimate concern what is it should
you have one right now my ultimate
concern certainly involves making sure
that this little guy is happy and
healthy and has an opportunity to look
at himself in various mirrors but I
don't know if it should be limited to
that should your ultimate concern be
limited to your family should it be
about politics or policy about your
community or your nation or the human
species should it take into account
other species and if so should those
species be treated as equal to humans or
should self-preservation and our own
needs Trump everything and when did my
husky voice transform into the voice of
a pubescent boy those are my non
rhetorical questions of the week I'll
see you on Wednesday
yeah did you just sigh because you're
bored of me video blogging Willy says
I'm still here and I'm cute too how we
gonna kick it going to kick it tummy
time yes and Henry's favorite rap songs
include how we gonna kick it gonna kick
it tummy time no sleep til burpin and of
course who's down with OPP dad's down
with OPP you know other people's poop